hi we're extreme
hi I'm Maya hi I'm Julian hi I'm
hi
I'm Julia I am Hinata I am Harvey and
we're here with BuzzFeed to play who's
who let's get started yay
[Music]
most likely okay who's most likely yeah
not who actually okay three two one
oh
okay I know this one yeah I got it three
two one
she is the dance leader
I chose
three two one
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
yes three two one me
Jesus
[Music]
oh thank you
[Applause]
I know you look like Square what
decent ah girl
you're so sweet thank you
yeah
it's so funny and yeah YouTube
[Applause]
um
yes
[Music]
okay definitely okay
that's true that's true
okay okay
[Music]
three two one
yeah
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
I got it oh okay
cuts
[Laughter]
[Music]
definitely
three two one
[Applause]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no reason
foreign
[Music]
I know this one okay okay because I use
the same room as her
okay three two one yeah
[Applause]
foreign
yes
[Music]
this is
um yeah
wait
[Laughter]
okay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
she's so smart
okay
she's so reliable though yes yes yes
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Laughter]
three two one
[Applause]
yes
yeah yeah I think I can't yeah
foreign
[Music]
three two one
tomorrow
[Music]
okay yeah
[Applause]
always yeah who is acting yeah you're
always acting yeah
one two three
questions
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh DIY something okay three two one
I actually made
um a phone case yeah
still good
thank you BuzzFeed please check out our
latest song left right
thank you thank you
[Music]
thank you